just when you thought the BS was over
the CDC now wants you to wear masks with
your Santa hats CDC director Dr Rochelle
walensky encouraging people quote to
wear high quality well-fitting masks to
prevent the spread of respiratory
illnesses you see that during the busy
holiday season as covid flew and RSV
cases Spike meanwhile the largest county
in the country La is on track to bring
back indoor mask mandates and even as we
continue this forever pandemic retiring
Dr fauci says he has no regrets on his
way out is there a moment of your career
that you wish you could do over yes me
no and I know they're going to people
are going to respond to that
um who say well what does he think he's
perfect absolutely I'm the first to
admit I'm far from perfect but when you
say do over
you know I really can't see something
that I would do completely over ah then
you're lying to yourself you know Jesse
he's replaced elf on a shelf as a
persistent holiday nuisance he's fouchy
on a couchy he won't go away you're
tired too yeah but how can he say
everybody has regrets the smartest
people alive have regrets but this is
such a politician answer he says he's
not a politician but this is what you'd
get from a politician what have you done
wrong I've done so many things right
nothing comes to mind because you can
never admit a mistake remember the
b-roll we showed right at the top of
that segment there was a guy with a mask
with a face shield behind a plastic
divider he's probably had covered like a
dozen times I don't mind that we're
suggesting that we bring the masks back
I just don't like the Mandate that's my
problem but Newsome's going to be in a
tough spot because if LA County
officially brings back the Mandate
what's he gonna do that's not going to
look good for Gavin Newsom he has to get
beyond that and if he he's still
following the science to mask mandates
that's bad and if 8 out of 10 CDC
workers are still working from home
quarantining and they're quadruple
boosted and they're supposed to know
about being healthy that's something
yeah that tells me this is not about
catching covet they just want to watch
TV all day yeah and Geraldo did you
notice that when they said masking and
they moved on Beyond covid so there's no
going back they mentioned respiratory
illnesses RSV
yeah one of my grandchildren had RSV
it's a real thing it's a flu-like
Illness but he but here's the deal I
mean In fairness even in La where they
have reparations coming in every other
kind of crazy thing happening they say
that they will only trigger a mask
mandate if 10 of Hospital admissions are
related to uh covet or respiratory
disease so you have to have 10 of the
people in the hospital that are
suffering from the malady before you
even get to triggering so they say
at worst it'll be in the uh in the late
winter at best they'll be with the
boosters and everything else they'll
beat it how much you want to bet
um let me be optimistic Christmas
let me tell you something this whole
like first of all when Rachelle wolinsky
says you know what you got to make sure
you get a good mask make sure it's
fitted properly and all that we now know
that the fabric ones don't work that you
should get to pay for one but the paper
ones don't fit right what if they tell
you which one to wear do you know which
one to wear no okay and here's the thing
once they start recommending you mask
not just for covert but for the flu you
don't want to get your flu you want to
get the respiratory illness then uh it's
going to be easy to segue to a mandated
mask a mass mandate that's the easy
slippery soap and I got to tell you I'm
not so sure that that Newsome would be
reluctant to mandate The Masks because
that's part of the Democrat creds I care
about you I care about Grandma I want to
protect you you know it's him that's a
badge of honor no I don't know about
nationally though that's not a good look
I'm in 2023 yeah and 10 is well his
reparations a good look yes that's
wrestling
so Dana I look okay I you know I always
see the glass half full your whole life
exactly is this a great excuse not to
see some relatives like it's the perfect
time to to say hey look I'm sorry uh
Aunt what's her name Bertha sure yeah
let's keep it going 20 years in a row
yeah I'm doing it for you I'm I can't
put your lives at risk or is this some I
mean I do feel like America has moved on
we've been we've Incorporated this risk
with all the other risks that we deal
with every day there was one thing that
she said along the way of the last
couple of days where it was like you you
shouldn't have to wait for a mandate to
protect yourself so make your make your
best decisions and I think that's where
they should leave it the Public Health
Community has admitted in fact they did
yesterday that they are speaking from a
Communications whole like the deficit is
really down there so they got to crawl
out of that and if if you suggest a mask
for certain people great but I'm just
telling you America's not going there
plus did you see the story today about
the mental health challenges of teens in
this country what they went through in
the last two and a half years one in
five have had Suicidal Thoughts one in
five that's a crisis look at the
learning loss that's not just because
they were doing Zoom schools because
they can't see anybody talking and it's
a huge problem
um the other thing is there's the
government is saying that and maybe your
doctor as well is saying the flu vaccine
is actually a good match this year
against the flu so if you've got the flu
vaccines you have to also wear a mask
but that mandate stuff coming back
brings up all those angry feelings that
people have about it letting people make
good decisions based on their own
experiences is the best way for them to
go right now there you go
you should run the CDC oh nothing yeah
the odds are eight attendance she'd stay
home that's true you could do it from
your couch yep and I'll be speaking in
my personal capacity
yeah I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now